welcome back everyone to the beginner to
Master speedrun episode number 20 coming
into today rated
1139 on a 67 game win streak and let's
hop into it playing ZZ
Speedy I'll see how speedy my opponent
is okay we have a
kocon uh against a kokan there's a lot
of different things to play uh D4 is the
most classical move I'm to play A
variation called the two knights attack
which goes after D5 to play Knight
C3 and I made a video about this a few
years ago uh just showing kind of the
basic strategy the kind of common lines
from this opening Bishop G4 is one of
the most common moves uh simply pinning
the Knight and against this move I'll
just play
H3 very often black will take and uh
kind of give away the bishop ha and then
try and get the pawns on the light
squares so we do see Bishop
F3 uh in other openings it's usually not
a great idea to take on F3 so early but
uh it is a common approach for black in
this line and now I have a choice here
between taking with the queen or the
Knight I'm going to take with Knight if
I were to take with Queen the Knight of
six would uh win
time so pretty solid position so far
have the knighting Queen developed black
has nothing
developed traded off the the only
developed piece with the bishop but yeah
after Knight F6 it's still kind of a
question how to
proceed um if I
take then I think black would be likely
to take back with the pawn I'm not
really achieving much cuz then after
like Bishop D6 and castling black will
have a very safe King side so we'll TR
try and be active here play the move
Bishop to
C4 uh which essentially pins the Knight
to F7 so if takes I could First Take on
F7 and then
recapture but so far I think um I mean
black is playing solidly a move like
Knight D7 yeah it's very fine
reinforcing the Knight black maybe is
threatening this move Knight
E5 uh now there is a move that comes to
mind here Queen to
B3
which it's aggressive uh because it
attacks F7 and B7 pawns but it would
leave this Knight undefended of course
black wouldn't be able to take because
of Bishop F7 mate but if I play Queen
B3 there's something like Knight
E5 defending and pressuring the
bishop
seems a little bit too risky for white
so I'm going to just play the move d4
just seizing space in the center uh
preventing Knight E5 which I think was
one of the big
threats uh E6 okay solid
move and we'll keep
completing
development I could play Bishop G5 to
pin but then Bishop E7 not sure if I
want to commit my Bishop so early so
I'll just Castle here here staying
solid also staying flexible CU maybe the
bishop will come here maybe even to
E3 and sometimes when you're not sure
where exactly to develop the piece uh
you just want to play other useful moves
first so castling is a move that I'm
pretty sure that I I wanted to play of
course I maybe could have considered
casting Queen side maybe black is
considering that here Queen B6
um also attacking the
pawn so what to do you know move like
Rook D1 or C3 let simply defend even
Bishop
E3 Bishop E3 is interesting because it
loses B2 but then maybe allows for some
counterplay not sure if I want to even
allow that
though I'm going to play
C3 staying very very solid creating the
pawn
chain still staying flexible with the
bishop to and I didn't play Rook D1
because maybe The Rook wants to go to E1
uh this is the only half openen file for
me it's only file where I don't have a
pawn and usually Rooks like to be on
such
files so black may be trying to figure
out how to complete development from
their end I mean the bishop really
doesn't have any of these squares so
Bishop E7 I think is most likely and
then black can maybe choose whether to
Castle King side or queen
side I would be surprised if black
Castle's Queen side immediately and
actually if black Castle's Queen side
maybe I would have Knight G5 to win the
F7
Pawn so we do see Bishop
E7 and now what to
do I mean Bishop E3 is beginning to look
more
attractive simply aligning with the
queen and if Queen takes
B2 I can win the pawn back I have a move
like Rook B1 and Rook takes
B7 and I think that would be a good
trade for
white uh now if I play Bishop
E3 black has this move Knight
D5 so I'm not sure if I'm getting much
there realizing the the bishop is
probably just happier on
F4 because Bishop E3 Knight D5 the
bishop just kind of a dead piece on this
diagonal Pawn would be
blockaded yeah let's go for Bishop f4 on
this diagonal it has the idea of either
Bishop D6 or Knight
D6 which is it's a square deep in
Black's
territory that's more controlled with my
pieces and I mean probably the threat is
Knight D6 to check the king and if takes
takes the bishop would be preventing
black from
casting and then I would have two
Bishops against two knights which is
generally a good
imbalance um of course in this line I'm
still allowing black to take the pawn
but I think I'd be happy to get the Rook
into
play so my opponent uh not playing Super
Speedy definitely taking their time as a
small time
advantage
I mean one thing black can consider here
is taking on e4 getting rid of my knight
and then bringing the other Knight to F6
and this would gain time on my queen I'd
probably play something like Queen E2 or
C2 and stay
solid but I still like the fact that I
mean I have the bishop
here because of the the early trade of
Pawns in the center the position is
decently open so it's like a a nice
position to have the two Bishops
if black castles King side then maybe
there's some attacking potential maybe I
can drop back this bishop and start
targeting some uh squares on the king
side so officially up on time
now we see Pawn
C5 which is not a move I was expecting
but it is a common idea espe especially
from these carocon structures to exert
pressure in the
center um and this move also allows back
to control D6 so it is preventing Knight
D6 or Bishop
D6 and now I have to figure out like
what to do with this Pawn
tension if I
take it could lead to some
trades pushing doesn't work I black can
just
take although pushing yeah even Knight
takes so I don't want to do that I'm
taking a moment here to consider the
options I mean something like Rook
D1 just to reinforce the pawn maybe
taking first and then Rook
D1 yeah because I I don't think I want
to allow black to
take if I play Rook D1 then maybe black
starts with taking and then takes and it
just seems like an unnecessary risk
so let's
take this could lead to some
trades black likely to take back with a
knight and with more trades of Pawns the
position is opening up further which
again should favor the Bishops in the
long run the block takes with the bishop
here so if I want to I could snag it and
have the two Bishops against two knights
yeah let's go for
this if black takes with the queen maybe
I can take on B7 counterattacking the
rook and then black would have no time
to take the
bishop so black should probably take
with a knight
here but we do see takes with Queen
so I have to be very careful that I'm
not walking into any
problems
but yeah this looks good for me because
Rook B8 is met with Bishop takes B8
Queen takes C4 is that with Queen takes
a with
chck black was playing the first part of
the game solidly but I think I'm getting
away with with the Free Pawn and I don't
think black is getting much compensation
now this bishop is still attacked
so should either defend it or move
it
Bishop
D3 one thing about Bishops is they don't
like to stare at Pawn chains and the
bishop on C4 was kind of staring it was
a very solid chain on D3 it's a bit more
centralized aims at H7 which could be a
bigger
Target again Rook B8 is off limits black
could play
E5 but then I can play Bishop E3 to
attack the
queen and meanwhile the queen is
actually kind of nice here cuz
this Knight is tied down to this Knight
except okay V still moves this Knight
because if I
take then it's a
trade so do I want to actually take on
D7 I mean Bishop
E3 there's Knight
takes I have to move a bit quicker here
too uh what to do I think I'd rather
keep the bishop on the
board like it's a nice piece helps
defend the king side pierces through the
diagonal black now has a chance to play
this
move yeah my queen is looking a little
bit uh delicate on B7 like this almost
trapped the
queen
um but yeah okay I'm I'm hitting the
Knight and I'm still covering B8 so
everything is fine
and if if we do see this
move maybe I'll just drop back to B3 and
come back to
C2 but we see Knight B6 so black is
trying to keep my queen in their
territory I don't see how black is
actually trapping it though so I'm going
to play Rook
D1 I mean just centralizing one of the
Rooks this only open file on the
board
okay it looks like black forgot about uh
my Bishop on G3 a sniper Bishop I think
it's a common mistake like at this
rating level sometimes um not seeing the
whole board seeing the connections from
King side to Queen side in this
case and now yeah now I'm up a rook in
addition to the extra
pawn and now this Rook is being hugged
tightly by my queen and Bishop it's
defended by the Knight though so rook's
not actually trapped I mean overall my
opponent played a pretty solid game but
I mean I was probably just more solid
like
I've I put my pieces on good squares and
eventually my opponent gave some free
material uh black is offering a queen
trade here yeah let's trade Queens happy
to simplify
with extra Rook now we'll bring the
bishop back it'd be funny if we see Rook
B8 making the same mistake
oh okay yeah sometimes you have to make
the the same mistake multiple times to
actually learn from it okay that was um
that was a funny
finish uh maybe there is some tilt from
blundering the the first Rook from my
opponent but hopefully it's still some
some instructive moments from this game
from the
opening uh we saw very solid variation
of the carocon two kns attack I will
link the two nights video that I made
about this opening below if you want to
check it out it was a video from a few
years ago but I think it's still
Evergreen
content and um yeah from my experience
like sometimes black should just play E6
here try and keep the position closed
with uh White having the two
Bishops um and then in this game I mean
black probably should
have probably should have traded on e4 a
bit sooner gained time on my queen and
then something like Bishop D6 I think is
fine um of course okay I probably should
protect the pawn like Queen D3 then
Bishop D6 and Castle King side and this
would be a relatively level
position so anyway uh that was the first
game of the episode now rated 11 46
let's move on to the second game playing
zebra
1965 and we'll have another Kings Pawn
opening I say another Kings Pawn opening
referring to the fact that I think most
of the games in the speedrun series have
been in the King's Pawn
opening uh and it's a four knights with
Bishop C4 so this does allow the center
fork trick which I think is a very
common
variation at this rating level my
opponent's going for Bishop takes F7
understanding that if Knight takes I win
back the piece so they're trying to kind
of get the most for the minor
piece but uh in this case even though it
looks scary that my king is exposed lost
casting rights uh this is just known to
be much much preferable for black king
hides on G8 I have the center
H6 is coming E4 is
coming um I've actually been asked about
this variation a lot whenever I show the
the center fork trick people ask what
about Bishop takes
F7 and it's nothing to be scared of if
you're playing this position with the
black pieces this Knight's going to be
kicked back to
H3 and yeah then I'll have very L
development with a bishops probably
start with Bishop to
G4
I mean one thing about like
determining whether your king is weak in
in chess uh the king is usually only
weak if the opponent can effectively
attack it and even though okay I don't
have an F Pawn uh this dogal might be
more open uh there's just no way for
white to exploit the king now White's
trying to play Super aggressively
sacrificing the Knight I'm happy to take
it and if Knight comes in I'm going to
have way more Defenders even if the
bishop comes
in um I have more pieces to defend with
than white has to attack
with and now I'm uh really just looking
to
trade uh I could take on
G5 could also start with Bishop to
G4 think I kind of prefer Bishop
G4 completing
development really just looking to trade
on F3 and then trade on
G5 and there is this tension on the H
file as well so like if it's my move and
I can take and then take and then
take uh is going to say that maybe it
could lead to winning The
Rook um but here now the Rooks are
connected so I'm realizing if I take on
F3 it would help open the G file for
white I mean of course
it is nice to trade but I really don't
want to give
white any source of counterplay or or
fun in the
position so I'll take a moment here
to try and figure out the most solid
continuation I could also play
E4 which is maybe not the solid type of
move that I'm probably looking for
but maybe it can win material against
Knight E4
take take that could walk into problems
though like Queen F4 would attack the
bishop and then my queen as well so E4
might be playable but it's probably not
a
move I don't want to actually spend too
much time on
so and there's a move here
that it really doesn't Force matters in
the
position but I think I'm going to go for
is Queen
D6 it's really just a solidifying move
putting the ball back in White's Court
keeping the Knight pinned keeping the
tension between the Bishops and uh also
aiming to get my Rook to
f8 I also over defend the pawn so yeah
no no need to worry about Knight takes
E5 and yeah let's just put the Rook on
f8 um so this move and this move it's
really just optimizing the pieces I mean
the and Rook are a bit happier now a
knight is now yeah was unpinned so now
it's attacking the
bishop but I'll just move
back and sometimes this is just the the
strategy to go for when you're up
material you just want to be solid try
and just dominate uh the center in this
case and not really Force matters I mean
White's trying to create some some type
of attack
but
here let's go ahead and
take even though it opens the E file
Queen defends the bishop and the queen
also helps defend the pawn along with
the
Rook so I think that was a free
Pawn Knight moves
back okay White's keeping
tension maybe now it's time
to to
take but then the Knight comes
in any other
options I guess white wants to take and
then play Knight G5
which might be a little bit hard to
stop so I think I will go for Bishop G4
he moving the bishop back so it's not a
Target and Bishop on E7 has defended
enough time Times by the queen of
Knight and white could take and then
take but again I don't mind
trading I'm thinking long term if I can
keep the pawn on F4 I mean this E3
Square would be really nice for my
knight I can't teleport there
immediately oh this is funny so White's
going for maybe
repetition uh if I move back but
let's move back this
way so keeping the bishop on this
diagonal so if the Knight moves back
then I can consider
trading and if
not I think now the time has come
to take the
bishop yeah the Bishops were staring at
each other for long
enough and I'm happy with most of my
pieces like The Bishop's fine
here and this Knight is really the one
piece not doing much in the
position so I'm going to maneuver start
with
97 and I'm mainly trying to figure out
how I can get to E3 like Knight F5
now looks pretty
good it does obstruct The Rook from
defending the pawn but white also
obstructed their Rook from attacking the
pawn
so it's fine that the pawns only
defended once and attacked
once and even if like goes in with the
Knight I can go in with my
knight it does look a little bit messy
like our Knights are are in each other's
territories but with this move I'm
attacking the rook and obstructing this
Rook from defending the Knight so white
saw this but didn't quite see this
winning another piece
now now it's cleanup
time yeah I could on pant but that
leaves a knight undefended so I'll take
the free G5 Pawn I feel like this game
had maybe a slightly similar theme to
the first game really just a matter of
being solid and
patient and jumping on opportunities for
free
material um but also a very important
opening lesson in this game like Bishop
C4 it's played at especially this raing
level but uh generally it's not
recommended like if you play the Four
Knights as white i' recommend either the
for Knight Scotch which is D4 here or uh
the main line which is Bishop to
B5 but Bishop C4 is exploited and of
course if takes then D5 is very powerful
um I maybe had one game previously in
the speedrun earlier episode and just to
show if Bishop B5 there's takes and
takes and then Queen D5 it's a nice move
to attack and defend black just
dominates the center
here um but as we saw Bishop takes F7
it's also very nice for
black and uh yeah white gave the night
and it was a pretty smooth game from
there so let's do one more we have 1152
nice
rating uh new 10
game playing Moto L from the
USA G6 pre moved okay so I wonder if
Bishop G7 will be
preed it's not but D6 comes very quickly
so uh this is what we call the modern
defense which usually employs a setup
with Bishop
G7 and then um it's similar to the PS
where Knight F6 is included against this
I'm just going to develop uh prioritize
the kingside development knight3 and
Bishop C4 getting ready to
Castle and there are a few potential
traps in this position uh Knight F6 does
not walk into a trap if I remember after
the game I can show a few ways black can
go
wrong uh against this move I've I've
encountered this position a lot uh in in
higher level games and the move I like
to play is Queen
E2 uh maybe the more natural move would
be Knight C3 to defend and develop the
point of to is to actually support this
Pawn E5 uh break which I'll play right
away it's a nice way to just attack the
Knight there's cases where this move can
be considered overextending or
weakening but uh yeah the Knight and the
Queen and potentially later the bishop
or maybe a rook can support the pawn so
gaining space
early usually black should
take and and yeah then I'll take back
and then there's Knight
D5 um I did play this opening I think
this exact position once against
Hikaru uh it was our Infamous game where
Hikaru was winning it was on leest he
was like begging for me to resign uh
because I blundered but then I ended up
tricking him and beating him pretty sure
Caro played Knight G7 in that game
Knight
H5 probably not as good the knight's
very close to being trapped here if I
could play G4 it would trap the
Knight controlling F4 with the
bishop so there's a move here which is
very multi-purpose which I think I'll go
for which is
H3 and not only preventing Bishop G4
which is one of Lock's main developing
squares for this bishop but I'm also
preparing G4 to trap the
Knight and black might have to do some
contortions to save the nine and
H5 it's not easy to prevent this move
like F5 is not legal and yeah Bishop h8
is a a
funny sort of contortion that if I play
G4 then black does have Knight
G7 looks really ugly for black but I'm
not actually winning the
Knight now the question is do I want to
still go for
G4 I also have Bishop H6 with some um
nice
initiative I could also just castle and
follow basic
principles so there's a choice
here I mean if I play G4 Knight
G7 yeah the knight's just so ugly there
it blocks the bishop and then I can play
Bishop H6 and pin the Knight to The Rook
I'm going to go for this there are cases
where like I mean sometimes the general
rule is you should not push or push
pawns on the side that you plan to
Castle but I haven't committed to
castling and my King's also just safe in
the center so I think it's fine just
chilling on
E1 and I mean if Knight G7 comes
then after I play Bishop
H6 I'll just have a very active
position and maybe some point I can
Castle Queen side and then focus on a
pawn storm on the king
side so it's a feel good opening so far
but I do have to give my opponent credit
for saving the Knight because that may
have been the only way to do
so an
E6 yeah
um I mean it's kind of an ugly move
which restricts the Knight and the
bishop but it also blocks my Bishop from
causing any harm D5 might be coming
next now one thing that comes to mind in
this position if I can get a knight to
F6 that's almost smothered M it would
force Queen
F6 so I'm thinking Knight D2 or Knight
C3 to get into E4 but Black's in time to
play
D5 so I'm wondering if it's if it's
worth trying to prevent E5 but it's not
an easy move to prevent
like taking I don't think accomplishes
much I think I'll just complete
development Knight D2 if black plays D5
I'll drop the bishop back and then the
center would be closed
down and then the focus of play can
really just shift to the king
side I'm thinking maybe at some point
Bishop
G5 Bishop F6 could be an
idea and then combine that with pushing
the pawn maybe getting the queen to H6
still a very rich position with a lot of
attacking ideas for
wh you see
B6 so yeah maybe the bishop wants to
come to
B7 would be a nice Square for
it but with B6 uh and not
D5 I do have the option of playing
this and yeah I'm not going to spend too
much more time here let's go for this
I am allowing the fork but if that goes
for the fork then I have a very strong
uh counter punch so yeah D5 would be a
big blunder here it might be necessary
for V to play this
move which would then lose a
rook it'd be funny if we see this move
allowing the the smothered mate
Fork
we see Rook
E8 uh and this gives a square for the
king but still
allows Knight F6 which I mean this is
pretty devastating for black it's still
a fork actually not interested in taking
the Rook I'm more interested in taking
the pawn with
check if King goes back I can go back if
the king moves
E7 then I can skewer
so very difficult position for black
here uh of course I I don't want to
repeat and and uh take a three-fold
repetition like even if I was playing uh
Magnus Carlson or even
stockfish white should should be winning
here even if black plays uh plays
perfectly from here
but how to how to maximize my
advantage I could start with Bishop
G5 which sets up this
check I guess Bishop G5 there's Rook
E7 yeah I'm really just looking for the
the cleanest put away there's also
Knight G5 idea of Knight H7 but then the
king can run of course I could take the
Rook but I think I'll start with Bishop
to
G5 I just like the bishop aligned with
the
queen and yeah King E7 of
course no longer a good option for
Black Knight H7 is very likely to come
next
move yeah I just have to be careful not
to spend too much time we do see rookie
so yeah do I want to leave my knight
on on F6 or do I want to cash in the
material I don't think there's any need
to cash in I'm going to play
H4 very simple idea of um just getting
the Rook involved maybe getting the pawn
to H6 or
trading as the king's going nowhere
anytime I'll have the H7 so I'll keep
black very much in a bind
here Knights controlling these SAR so
it's it's so hard to
untangle like the king rook and queen
are pretty much all paralyzed along with
the bishop and the Knight and there is
Knight
E8 and then I could then I can cash in
probably I mean maybe we'll see black do
something on the queen side Bishop
B7 at least a somewhat active
move or Knight
D7 well I'm not too afraid of Knight
takes Knight because then I take back
with Pawn with the
fork so let's go for
H5 okay now I'll I'll take back and
likely be winning a lot of material here
because if I end up taking the Knight
Will unleash the skewer I'm also
threatening to take the Rook which Forks
the king and
queen so it seems like I'm not just
winning The Rook or the Knight I'll be
winning a bit
more not to mention when I take this I
unleash the Rook which actually traps a
bishop in the
corner so I'm really spoiled for Choice
here
like taking I mean taking wins the
queen
but taking here thr's
mate let's just take the Knight wi the
queen and then later I'll open the H
file probably get my queen
involved youan of course black can
breathe a little bit more
easily now that uh yeah some some pieces
have come off the board
okay so my knight is a bit pinned but
let's uh I'm trying and work to expose
the black king if King takes it's
actually made in two with Queen takes
E6 and
here now I don't think I mind allowing
Bishop takes H1 Knight will come
in I take the Rook it's double check
so black can't actually take the
Knight now it's time to try and finish
things off
efficiently get the queen
in Queen H5 will be
checkmates okay uh pretty nice game
things definitely got sour for
black pretty quickly in the opening I
mean I do have to give my opponent
credit for like really trying to survive
I mean they kind of turned into a what
do we call it
Hedgehog or rly py type creature just
trying and roll up in a ball and
sometimes that's uh the best strategy
but I just had too many too many
attacking ideas uh especially once my
knight got to
F6 um so black probably should have
played D5 in this position at least to
prevent Knight E4 and then then black
maybe could have played C5 and tried to
exert pressure in the center and um and
it's at least it's a bit more difficult
for white to
attack um of course earlier if Black's
playing this opening and runs into this
line again then the best approach is to
take
take and because the defile is now open
the queen would support the Knight
coming to
D5 and this is just a lot more pleasant
because the knight's in the center
rather than on the side and then there's
ideas of Bishop G4 and C6 or Knight C6
and life would go on from here
so I think a nice kind of collection of
games for today's episode uh a lot of
the games featured kind of just full
domination but hopefully a lot of
lessons to take away so as usual if you
like the content do subscribe it does
help the channel grow uh if you have
questions leave them below look forward
to reading the comments and stay tuned
for the next episode see you guys soon